4.99 that's where miguel cabrera sits
right now one more and he will go where
only 27 others have gone tyler alexander
32nd appearance this year only his
eighth start
been finding it now he found it there
miles straw did not a strikeout to start
the night for tyler alexander
zach please sack will be the indian
starting pitcher tonight looking to be a
little more aggressive and making some
adjustments to for that slider
robbie grossman drills one into the
right field corner
grossman will dig for second he starts
tonight what a stand-up double looking
for something out over the middle of the
plate and he gets it right down the
middle you know who's coming to bed now
everybody
on their feet here at comerica park what
a sight now the one two
swung out
miller up the middle
sunday hop on a friday night how about
these two first innings for tyler
alexander strong first inning no score
he'll face ronaldo nunez
swinging a miss down goes nunez one away
second strikeout for police trying to
get to the outside part of the plate
made a nice pitch and had a nice result
got the swing and miss
there it is beautiful a couple of k's
here in the second tigers go in orders
two outs nobody on no score third inning
and here's ernie clement
swung on this is hammered to deep right
field back goes grossman on the track
this ball is gone
ernie clement
with his first major league home run
and he now closes the gap he trails
miguel cabrera by only
498. got on a fastball mat out over the
plate 90. so that ball didn't cut and
that was really a nice approach staying
on it going it that way ahmed rosario
grounded out his first time up
ground ball up the middle and through
here comes mile straw two-nothing
cleveland so that's 28 hits with runners
in scoring position and 28 runs batted
in there you go and an outstanding job
the third consecutive two-out hit
good pitch painted it yeah he did
if ron male reyes was ejected from the
game as we went to the commercial break
it was uh let's call it a difference of
opinion well he's letting the umpire
that it was a ball the umpire said no so
he let him have his say he goes back and
then he said something and now now he's
gone and that's gonna cost your team
that's not that's not good for the
indians now they lose him for the rest
of the game major league start for jacob
robson
swinging a missed good pitch bottom fell
out of that one fourth strikeout for
pleisek first time through the order
grossman doubled down the right field
line his first time up
struck him out looking with a fast wall
euchang finds the gap that's up the
alley that's gonna go all the way to the
wall oh and miller he's gonna score all
the way from first and racing around
second on his way to third as you change
the throws not in time it's an rbi
triple for you
his second triple of the year
rbi number 17 for chang and it's three
to nothing cleveland if you can plug the
gap like he does as a right-handed
hitter and you run average or better
you're going to have yourself a triple
austin hedges will be at the plate with
chang at third trying to put it in play
he does just that
oh deep enough sacrifice fly well done
the throw is not going to be there it's
cut off
another run home hedges rbi number 19.
he does his job
and the indians score two more to make
it four to nothing
he's been sharp he's been crisp he's
been getting ahead in the count
good pitch
again on the outside corner he's dotting
the fastball man he's not messing around
with the breaking ball with two strikes
they're taking and i love it here comes
miguel cabrera the 2-1
a fly ball to center
mile straw drifts over takes command two
away here's his pitch
swing and a missed strike three got him
upstairs that time
slider again strikeout number seven this
is eric haas
he drives one to deep center field that
is pounded straw looks up that's it in
the bushes
eric haas
powers up and the tigers are on the
board wow eric haas
who've been in a little bit of a slump
breaks out in a big way and gets the
tigers on the board he is so strong
doubling a strikeout for grossman so far
tonight the 0-1 jack to right
that ball is down and up against the
wall grossman comes through again his
second double of the night this time it
brings in a run and it's 4-2 cleveland
grossman is on it beat the [ __ ]
base is empty sixth inning tribe up five
to two it'll bring up you chang and
death balls hit pretty hard deep left
field drops it back looking up it is
gone
into the bullpen and you chang is having
himself a night well he went down he got
a fastball chang likes it down but he
ended up turning on this one his power
alley normally right center field that
you see him hit it but this one stayed
up a little bit for him but a good swing
on it and this one gets out tigers down
four in the bottom of the six miguel
cabrera his third at bat of the night
chopper to third
one away
eric holland fastball curveball slider
changeup
leading off and hammering it to left
ernie clement forget about it
a two homer game for ernie clement his
first two in the big leagues
a line drive solo shot to right in the
third
and a mammoth blast to left here in the
seventh and it is
to 7-2 indians and did he tee off zach
please back out here 76 pitches on the
night in the one-two
swinging a miss striking out good slider
in the dirt eight strikeouts for play
sack
hedges in the air
left side long run for everyone robson
sliding and making the grab
beautiful job on a pop-up to get hedges
to end the eighth zach playsack how
about that getting a chance to go out
for the eighth i like it the pitch
outside corner strength three called one
down nine strikeouts for policing
ground ball first base routine play
miller takes it himself and that's gonna
be it tonight demarlo hale who's gonna
go to brian shaw heck of a job here we
go new baseballs
for the cabrera had that
fly ball center field
straw is there
and the tigers are out in the eighth
rally caps are on here's ronaldo nunez
today here's the one-two
driven to deep left field back goes
mercado that ball's gone
nunez put a charge into that one it's
now 7-4
victor reyes trying to keep the game
alive for detroit
slow topper to second
quick flip book it the indians win it by
a final score of 7-4